okay all right here's the way i'm gonna
do this um some people have mentioned
that they need a little more time and i
think that's totally fine uh as you guys
know i'm a pretty slow writer so i'm
hopefully have i've hopefully given you
enough of a head start that we can we
can do this together even if you are not
quite finished yet
let's have a look at how we can break
this apart into
components for integration by parts
we'll choose our u and our dv uh and
then hopefully if we do some careful
algebra the result that we're required
to prove will just fall out okay here we
go remember that we select u
and dv based on what's easier to
differentiate and what's easier to
integrate and also in this case um we
have this we're not just like
integrating randomly in any random
direction we are trying to get towards
recall this i n minus 1 needs to appear
somewhere right so that should be the
clue that if i have
something which has a power of 2n when
you differentiate that once you use
chain rule that's going to bring it down
to 2n minus 1. that's kind of why i
chose to do this in the first place okay
so therefore what have i selected as my
u it's going to be this sine raised to
the 2n
of 2 theta okay and the reason why i'm
coloring this is because when i put this
into integration my parts in a second
it's going to be a mess of different
terms and i just want to help you see
what is what okay
so everyone sets it out slightly
differently but this is the way that
always has worked for me as soon as
you've got u i like to work out d u from
there so you can see my arrows sort of
going across the page this is chain rule
right so i'm going to bring the index
out the front i'm going to reduce the
index by one bam there's the 2n minus 1
that i needed for my i n minus 1
of 2 theta there's the outside
derivative and now i need to do the
inside derivative remember it's sine 2
theta
raised to this power so i just need the
derivative of sine 2 theta which
hopefully we remember is 2 cos 2 theta
there's u and d u
that leaves the dv to be the other part
that i broke out that single sine 2
theta and when you integrate that to get
to v
instead of multiplying of course we're
going to divide and just be careful
because you're going from you're
integrating up out of signs so therefore
you're like does cos differentiate down
into sine and the answer is no it
differentiates into negative sign
excuse me so therefore we need this
negative here to compensate if you were
differentiating the negatives would
cancel give you sine 2 theta
as we saw many times throughout our most
recent assessment task particularly
questions like vectors right it's these
done minus signs that keep getting us
right so you get the hard part and it's
the easy part that we get slipped up on
all right so from there let's remember
what does integration by parts actually
look like it's the integral of u dv
which is equal to uv minus
d u but we also need to recall in this
case i n is defined to be a definite
integral not an indefinite integral so
therefore we're going to have our
boundaries here and here and also we're
going to have our boundaries uh here on
this we're going to have to evaluate
what this uv is equal to and our upper
and lower bounds okay
all right so it's going to it's going to
be a very long line to begin with but we
need to substitute in all of our
different components which you can see
i've colored up in here okay so hold on
two hats here we go first i begin with
my u
v which is uh my blue and green bits
here right
so here it comes uh here's u sine to n
two theta
and here comes v me
negative a half cos 2 theta and i'm
going to integrate that from naught to
pi on 2. now
ordinarily i would just write out the
rest of the line but i'm just going to
pause for a minute just to highlight
what's going on here here's that v i'm
just trying to keep the colors the same
so you can see what's going on and
here's the u
it's almost like this question was
crafted for this exact purpose look
carefully at that u term in particular
what happens when you start to put in
your upper and lower bounds because even
though this thing looks horrendously
messy um it's being crafted to to come
out reasonably nicely for us just like
in a pythagoras theorem question they
give you like
nice round numbers right
think about what happens when you put in
the upper bound because that's the one
you evaluate first it's pi on two right
so therefore you're gonna go
sine of two times pi on two well what is
that that's sine of pi
hopefully by this point reflexively if
you picture the graph right you're like
what is sine doing when it gets over to
pi and the answer is it collides back
with the x-axis so it's equal to 0 right
so when you evaluate the upper bound
you've got 0
times something so i don't care what the
other stuff is so that's just gonna
vanish which is nice
and similarly when you do the lower
bound you're gonna do sine of two times
the lower bound is zero so sine of zero
and thankfully it's the same deal right
so even though this uv term it's like uh
gross it's all going to go it's all
going to vanish okay so that is really
promising for us
all right there's the beginning now we
do the integral of v
excuse me d u so we have our same
boundaries naught to pi on 2. here comes
v again so it's that same negative a
half cos to theta watch out for that
double negative that's obviously going
to cancel shortly
and then we're going to i'm going to be
you guys know how i love to be
exceptionally lazy i'm going to grab all
of this because it's just going to take
forever to write
there is my du okay so that is all
integrated with respect to theta and you
can see these terms here
are the same all right following so far
that's i am what a mess all right uh
we've already established that that
first part the uv the definite integral
is going to evaluate out to zero and
then we just need to tidy up what is
going on here in that
integral of the minus of integral of v d
u okay
we already mentioned there's the double
negatives that are going to cancel so
i'm just going to single signal that
here by going plus plus so i'm going to
say plus there
they're not the only things that cancel
right you can see i've got this half out
the front which is going to cancel with
this 2 so that's kind of convenient
but it does leave behind look at the
constant coefficients in this long
awkward integrand it leaves behind this
uh n
and this two okay so therefore i'm going
to pull them out the front and i might
as well just keep that color consistent
so you see where i did that from that's
a two n at the front and it's going to
go from naught to pi on two all right
what's left well we've got a couple of
sort of paired up terms here right so uh
what color have i not used yet i'm just
gonna have to pull out a new one i know
i've got a cos 2 theta there
and another cos 2 theta there so then
right out the front i'm just going to
combine those into a cos squared
2 theta
and then the last thing that i have is
the sine 2n minus 1 2 theta which i
needed because that's going to be part
of i n minus 1 okay so hopefully you're
following along with that let's just
write it down sine of 2n minus 1 to
theta
with respect to theta
okay now where is this going to go well
in order to get this
remember what result we're trying to
head towards right here it is right here
in order to get towards this you can see
here in terms of i n minus 1
i n i n minus 1 i n i everything right
it's all in terms of signs there it is
right there so the cos squared that's
appeared in my integrand i need to get
rid of that and replace it with some
sine terms and thankfully we've already
signaled it before earlier today i can
do that fairly easily with the
pythagorean identity so two ends hanging
out the front not to pi on two
and then if i substitute i'll keep with
the same color so that we don't get too
confused if i substitute this for 1
minus sine squared
of 2 theta
should have used beaker brackets out the
front there using square ones so we can
tell that apart everything along here is
remaining unchanged
you can see here i can start to combine
powers and it's going to work out
actually very nicely for me okay
we're pretty close i think we're on the
tail end it's mostly going to be algebra
from this point right so if you're
following along i'm just going to expand
out here leaves me with that 2n the not
pi on 2
and then let's see here so i'm going to
have a sine of 2n minus 1 to theta
because i'm just
multiplying that by one
and then when you put these together
just be careful with your indices
can you see that this is 2 and you're
adding it to this index so 2n minus 1
plus two
that brings you up to two n
plus one that's the original i n right
so therefore um if i write that it's a
minus careful for that sine of two n
plus one
two theta
and that's all integrated with respect
to theta okay
so just take a breath for a moment look
at this you're like ah this is the term
we were looking for for i n minus one
this one is from i
n so clearly i can actually put this
back in terms of all of our eye notation
and it's going to enable me to form the
relationship that part one was looking
for right so i can say on the left hand
side i n
on the right hand side 2 n multiplied by
this term here is the i n minus 1 term
so it's right there
and then this term here is the i n just
watch out for that minus sign here
minus i
n
okay there you go from here um just
because of time i'm so confident that
you can get from this point just expand
collect your i ns and then factorize out
this is going to give you after a couple
of lines of working that i n is equal to
2n on 2n plus 1
i n minus 1 as required so i'm going to
leave those couple of very simple lines
in between
for you to do
on your own